Erfassen sind wirklich meine letzte Hoffnung. Ich habe so viele Schmerzen, ich halte es nicht mehr aus.
Genau tut es Ihnen mehr.
Eigentlich habe ich diese Schmerzen seit meiner Kindheit.
Seit Kindheit haben Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie? Seit Kindheit? Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Wie bitte?
Wo genau tut es weh?
Mein ganzer Körper tut weh. Einfach überall.
Seit Kindheit?
Seit meiner Kindheit.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 43.
43. Wie alt sind Sie? Entschuldigung, wie heißen Sie?
Wie bitte?
Wie heißen Sie denn? Wie ist Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Winkler.
Winkler ist dein Nachname, oder?
Ja, mein Nachname ist Winkler.
Winkler mit W-I-N-K-L-E-R.
Ja, Winkler.
Wie ist Ihr Vornamen?
Markus.
Markus, Herr Winkler.
Ja.
Ihr Gebustdatum bitte, Herr Winkler.
Ich bin 75 Kilogramm.
75 Kilogramm. Ihr Gebustdatum?
Entschuldigung, habe ich nicht gut verstanden.
Haben Sie Probleme? Haben Sie Schwierigkeit beim Hören?
Ja, ich höre seit ein paar Jahren schlechter.
Vor allem wenn jemand leise spricht.
Seit ein paar Jahren?
Ja.
Haben Sie schon beim Ast wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Wegen Hörstörungen?
Ja, ja.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Haben Sie ein Gerät oder?
Nein, nein. So schlimm ist es nicht, aber ...
Ich hatte Hörtest, alles war unauffällig, aber es war manchmal schwer für mich zu verstehen.
Manchmal verwesse ich Wörter.
Ja, stimmt. Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Schmerzen im ganzen Körper.
Ja, ganzen Körper.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben diese Beschwerden seit Kindheit.
Warum sind Sie heute erst einmal hier gekommen?
Gibt es etwas Besonderes?
Nein, nein, alles ist egal.
Ich habe schon so viele Arztbesuche, aber keiner konnte mir helfen.
Der eine Arzt hat das gesagt, der andere war ganz anders.
Dann würde ich hier hin und dort hin und am Ende.
Keiner hat mir wirklich geholfen.
Finden Sie die richtige Diagnose oder wird es nie besser?
Wie bitte? Könnten Sie es wiederholen?
Ja, finden Sie die richtige Diagnose für mich.
Oder wird es ja nie besser?
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte, Herr Winkler.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Bleiben Sie ruhig, bitte.
Wurde bei Ihnen bisher eine Festdiagnose nicht gestellt, oder?
Nein, nein.
Wann war der letzte Besuch?
Ja, der letzte Besuch war vor zwei Monaten.
Also war der letzte Besuch.
Aber es war nicht gut.
Können Sie mir bitte erklären, welche Diagnostikmaßnahmen durchgeführt wurden?
Ja, manchmal hat der eine Arzt das gesagt, der andere war ganz anders.
Ich habe viele Medikamente probiert, aber Medikamente helfen mir gar nicht.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Winkler?
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten, Häsersen?
Nein.
Wie fühlen Sie sich, Herr Winkler?
Entschuldigung?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Haben Sie sich müde oder nervös?
Ja, manchmal fühle ich mich müde, erschöpft, aber müde.
Haben Sie Konzentrationsstörung?
Ja, ich habe.
Wünscht, wieder fragen, Ihr Gebüstdatum bitte?
Mein Gebüstdatum 1983.
1983. Sind Sie sicher?
Oder?
Sie sind 34 Jahre alt, aber Gebüstdatum 1983.
Ja, nicht 32. 42.
42.
Aber ich bin jetzt in ihrem Gebüstdatum.
Okay.
Drei, neun.
Sind Sie wie groß?
Ja, ich bin 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Ja, ich habe die Atemnoten. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter groß.
Ja Herr Doktor, könnte es nicht eine seltene Krankheit sein, die man überzieht?
Es ist zu früh etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Winkler.
Das ist ein Amnesgespräch. Danach werde ich eine köpferliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Aber wieso finden Sie keine ganzen Untersuchungen? Da muss doch etwas sein.
Wenn die normal sind, heißt das wirklich, dass ich gesund bin.
Ja, wenn alle Befunde normal sind, heißt das, dass Sie gesund sind. Sie sind ganz gesund.
Aber ich habe ganze Körperschmerzen.
Brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel? Könnten Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Nein, nein. Ich probiere viele, viele Medikamente. Medikamente helfen mir gar nicht.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie genommen?
Viele Medikamente.
Ist es welche Medikamente?
Ja, viele.
Ibuprofen, Paracetamol, Methimazol?
Ja, Schmerzmittel. Alle Schmerzmittel.
Aber es hat Ihnen nicht geholfen?
Nein, nein.
Ja.
Haben Sie Hautverfarbung oder Schwellungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Was ist Ihr Beruf, Herr Winkler?
Ich habe Ingenieurwesen studiert, aber wegen der Schmerzen müsste ich abbrechen.
Jetzt helfe ich meinem Vater. Mein Vater ist Ingenieur und er hat ein Büro.
Und helfe ich meinem Vater im Büro.
Haben Sie Stress im Leben?
Ich meine in Ihrer Familie, in Ihrem Freundkreis?
Nein, nein. Ich habe nicht so Stress.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich kann nicht jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja.
Haben Sie Fieber? Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen Schüttefrost oder Nachschweiß aufgefallen?
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Winkler?
Normal, manchmal gut, manchmal nicht.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Haben Sie besonders die Schmerzen, Kopfschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen.
Alle sind gleich, oder?
Ja, alle sind gleich.
Ist Ihr Schüttergang und Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich habe nicht.
Normal, besonders.
Können Sie gut schlafen, Herr Winkler?
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, ich habe viele Schmerzen, deshalb bin ich nicht gut.
Mögen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Winkler?
Nein.
Ich habe schon so viele Arztbesuche, aber ...
Blutdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, erhöhte Blutwerte?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Gut, ich freue mich.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Nein.
Vertragen Sie alles, ich meine Lebensmittel?
Lebensmittel? Entschuldigung?
Vertragen Sie alles.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Haben Sie volle Gefühle, Zutrennen, Ausstossen?
Herr Winkler?
Nein.
Aber, Doktor, können Sie eine Borreliose nehmen?
Wenn Sie eine Borreliose nehmen, können Sie die Arztstation erkennen.
Warum denken Sie an eine Borreliose?
Haben Sie ein Zeichen?
Nein.
Aber ich denke, es kann sich wichtig sein.
Können wir trotzdem einen Doktor testen?
Ja, wir können Laborkuntersuchungen durchführen, Herr Winkler.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ist Ihnen ein Krübel- oder Taubheitsgefühl aufgefallen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Muskelschwache?
Brauchen Sie, Herr Winkler?
Nein, ich habe nie.
Haben Sie davor geraucht?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Sehr gut. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus medizinischen Gründen.
Fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Nein, keine Drogen.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Winkler?
Leider nicht.
Sie sind ledig?
Ja, ich bin ledig.
Oder geschieden?
Nein, nein, ich bin ledig.
Aber ich möchte eine Familie setzen.
Haben Sie eine Freundin oder Partnerin?
Ja, bin ich oft rausgegangen, aber jetzt schaffe ich das kaum.
Meine Freunde suchen sich ohne mich und ich bleibe meistens zu Hause.
Ich hätte gerne eine Familie, aber mit diesen Schmerzen geht das nicht.
Wenn ich andere sehe, die glücklich verheiratet sind, macht mich das sehr traurig.
Ja, verstehe, Herr Winkler.
Bitte machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Wir tun am besten für Sie.
Okay, aber manchmal habe ich so Schmerzen, dass ich denke, ich überlebe das nicht.
Verstehen Sie das überhaupt?
Nein, Sie können es schaffen, Herr Winkler.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ja, wegen der Schmerzen gehe ich selten aus.
Ich hätte gerne eine normale soziale Situation.
Das ist unmöglich.
Verstehe.
In welchem Arzt haben Sie besucht?
Nur Hausarzt oder ...?
Nein, nein, ich habe einen neurologischen oder chirurgischen Arzt.
Ich habe viele Arzt, ja, Dutzende Arzt, besucht.
Aber keiner hat mir wichtig geholfen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, nein, ich möchte, aber ich habe nicht.
Mit wem wohnen Sie, Herr Winkler?
Ich lebe alleine.
Allein?
Allein, ja.
Gibt es Probleme im Alltag beim Kochen, Einkaufen oder Anziehen?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich habe viele Schmerzen.
Deshalb habe ich nicht jeden Tag Arbeit oder kaufen.
Aber ... ja.
Aber gibt es keine Probleme, oder?
Nein.
Gut.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, mein Vater ist gesund, aber meine Mutter hatte mal Depressionen, aber es geht jetzt wieder gut.
Und ich habe zwei Brüder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, alles.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Winkler?
Ja, ich habe.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich habe nicht viele rausgegangen.
Könnten Sie mir bitte wieder sagen, welchen Bereich haben Sie absolviert?
Individuell, aber in welchem Bereich?
Machendenbau.
Ja.
Aber ...
Manchmal arbeiten Sie mit Ihrem Vater?
Ja, im Büro kopieren, ordnen, shortieren.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen haben Sie Gedanken, dass Sie nicht mehr leben möchten?
Wegen der Schmerzen, ja, manchmal.
Haben Sie einen konkreten Vorsicht?
Nein, nein, nein. So schlimm ist es nicht. Aber ich bin fest frei.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, Sie ist meine letzte Hoffnung, Herr Wachter.
Könnten Sie es wiederholen?
Sie ist meine letzte Hoffnung.
Ja, was ist Ihre letzte Wohnung? Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Nein, nein, Sie sind wirklich meine letzte Hoffnung, ich meine.
Ah, sterben, oder?
Nein, ich möchte nicht sterben, ich möchte leben und Sie sind meine letzte Hoffnung.
Was ist Ihre letzte Hoffnung? Ich habe es verpasst, Entschuldigung.
Sie sind meine letzte Hoffnung.
Ja.
Gut. Bitte machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, Herr Winkler.
Wir tun alles für Sie. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, uns zu kommen.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Ja, meine Schmerzen eigentlich immer da. Manchmal stärker, manchmal schwerer.
Gibt es irgendetwas, das die Schmerzen besser oder schlimmer macht?
Nein, nein, Beratung, Stress macht es, es ist schlimmer. Aber egal, was ich...
Im Ruhe?
Ja, ich habe Angst, dass es etwas gefährlich ist.
Ja, stimmt.
Ah, ja.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Herr Winkler?
Nein, aber bitte lassen Sie mich nicht im Stich.
Ja, machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, wir sind für Sie da.
Okay. Das bedeutet mir viel und das wäre schön.
Gut zu hören, Herr Winkler.
Was ist das?
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, was ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Es handelt sich um Markus Winkler, ein 42-jähriger Patient, geboren am 3.9.1983.
1,78 Meter groß, 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Er ist seit seiner Kindheit bestehender Schmerzen im ganzen Körper.
Er hat sich seit ein paar Jahren an Höchststörungen und Problemen erklärt.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden war er vielmehr beim Arzt, bei verschiedenen Arzt.
Jedoch wurde bisher keine feste Diagnose gestellt.
Er hat viele verschiedene Medikamente eingenommen, aber es hat ihm noch nicht geholfen.
Die Frage nach Atemnot, Dyspnoe, Takikardie, Husten, Parasthesis, Parasie wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Insomni wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Bei ihm sind keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt. Er wurde noch nie operiert.
Es sind keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er ist nicht traurig, trinkt keinen Alkohol, drohigen Konsum wurde verneint.
Er ist ledig, lebt allein, hat keine Kinder.
Er ist Maschinenbauingenieur. Er arbeitet nur manchmal mit seinem Vater.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich eine Depression bei der Mutter.
Er ist vollständig geimpft. Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheorose lautet auf Depression.
Er leidet seit Kindheit an ähnlichen Beschwerden.
Er war schon vielmals beim Arzt, aber keine Festdiagnose gestellt wurde.
Depression ist eigentlich eine Ausschlussdiagnose.
Deswegen sollten wir mögliche organische Befunde ausschließen.
Meine differenziellen Diagnosen kommen.
Posttraumatische Belastungsstörungen.
Ist das ein Unfall?
Ich habe gefragt, ob es Probleme in ihrem Leben gibt.
Ich habe es nicht erklärt.
Ich habe eine Differenzdiagnose.
Hypotheriose Migräne.
Zuerst würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und ospiltieren.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich auf den Allgemeinzustand des Patienten.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken würde ich eine operative Diagnostik durchführen.
Ich würde eine Herzkrankheit ausschließen und eine EKG schreiben.
Um eine mögliche Herzkrankheit auszuschließen würde ich eine EKG schreiben.
Um eine neurologische Pathologie auszuschließen würde ich CT des Schadens oder gegebenenfalls MRT des Schadens durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstherapie bestätigen würde ich eine konservative Behandlung empfehlen.
Zuerst eine konservative Behandlung empfehlen.
Eine Gruppentherapie oder Psychotherapie empfehle ich.
Um die Therapie zu optimieren würde ich eine psychiatrische Konzilverhandlung verursachen.
Als Medikamentösebehandlung würde ich selektiv Serotonin wieder aufnehmen.
Ich würde auch eine Medikamentenhandlung empfehlen.
Aber diese Medikamente können nicht genutzt werden?
Ich habe es gefragt. Sie erinnern sich nicht. Sie haben sich nicht erinnert.
Aber kann der Patient antidepressiv sein?
Sie hat gesagt, nur Schmutzmittel, aber bisher hat er viele Asthen besucht.
Es gibt viele, die nicht.
Er hat viele Asthen besucht. Es könnte möglich sein, Frau Oberärztin.
Und hat der Patient eine Untersuchungsdokumente dabei?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich nachfragen.
Sie möchten die Patienten durchführen. Aber wann war der letzte Besuch?
Vor zwei Monaten war sie in einem Arzt. Aber ich weiß nicht, in welchem Abteil.
Manchmal hat der Patient eine MRT oder andere.
Sie haben schon gesagt, bei ihm wurde eine MRT durchgeführt mit normalen Befunden.
Aber vor zwei Monaten, um mögliche Pathologie auszuschließen, sollten wir auffrischen.
Und wie denken diese Patienten? Hat es eine Hautbeschwerde?
Was ist die Hautbeschwerde des Patienten?
Haut oder Haut? Hautbeschwerde.
Haut. Nein. Haut.
Hautbeschwerden sind Schmerzen.
Schmerzen. Okay.
Nicht die Patienten eine bestimmte Beschwerde, oder?
Er hat gesagt, Schmerzen in der Kanzlerkörper.
Ich habe vielmals gefragt, wo sie besonders Schmerzen haben.
Wo schpüren sie diese Schmerzen? Aber er hat gesagt, in der Kanzlerkörper.
Denken die Patienten andere Krankheiten für ihn?
Er hat einen Gedanken, noch Borreliose.
Denken Sie, dass es um Borreliose handeln könnte?
Ich habe es gefragt, haben Sie das Zeug bemerkt? Er hat mir gesagt, nein.
Okay. Und die Patienten, hat die Patienten stationär aufgenommen?
Ich habe über Suizid-Gedanken gefragt. Er hat keine Suizid-Gedanken.
Deswegen würde ich nicht stationär aufnehmen.
Okay. Bevor hat der Patient stationär aufgenommen?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt. Sie hat viele verschiedene Arzt besucht.
Aber diese Fragen habe ich nicht gestellt.
Okay. Und Sie schlagen für die Patienten eine psychiatrische Konstellation?
Ja. Ich schlage für eine psychiatrische Konstellation.
Wie sind Sie mit der Schwerhörigkeit des Patienten umgegangen?
Was würden Sie tun, wenn der Patient auf einer bestimmten Untersuchung besteht?
Was meinen Sie damit, Frau Berestink?
Der Patient hat Schmerzen oder eine Beschwerde. Was würden Sie tun für diese Patienten?
Zunächst würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Aber warte ich eine Befunde mit körperlicher Untersuchung?
Eigentlich warte ich keine Befunde.
Okay. Und möchten Sie andere Untersuchungen?
Ja. Ich würde sogar eine Global-Laboruntersuchung durchführen, um eine Hypotheriose auszuschließen.
Ich würde auch eine Laboruntersuchung durchführen und eine operative Diagnostik auch.
Okay. Hat der Patient Kontakt zu seiner Familie?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt, aber er arbeitet manchmal mit seinem Vater.
Und wie geht es seiner Mutter?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Okay. Aber ich habe diese Frage gestellt, ob sie Probleme im Leben haben, in ihrer Familie und in ihrer Arbeit.
Er hat gesagt nein.
Ja, stimmt. Welche bisherigen Therapien oder Untersuchungen gab es?
Er berichtete, dass er eine medikamentöse Behandlung gehabt hat.
Was ist Ihnen während des Gesprächs besonders aufgefallen?
Er braucht Hoffnung. Er sieht müde.
Okay. Und andere Fragen? Ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Das war wirklich ein typischer Behandlung.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, ob es diese in der letzten Zeit gibt.
Es gibt keine Hypochondriak, aber es gibt etwas anderes.
Der Patient hat eine Posttraumatik Stressbeschleunigung.
Ich habe heute die neuen Stuttgart-Behandlungen gesehen.
Woher habt ihr die Behandlung gesehen?
Aus dem Stich.
Ich berichte über den 42-jährigen Patienten, Herrn Markus Winkler, der 75 Jahre alt ist.
Er hat eine Posttraumatik Stressbeschleunigung.
Ich berichte über den 42-jährigen Patienten, Herrn Markus Winkler, der 75 Kilogramm wiegt und 1,78 Meter groß ist.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seiner Kindheit bestehenden ganzkörperlichen Schmerzen vor.
Ab oder zu nahm, Nausea, Emesis, Tachikardie, Arithmi, Dyspne, Fieber wurden verneint.
Der Patient hat schwache soziale Leben und hat zurzeit keine Arbeit.
Er hilft zu ihrem Vater im Büro.
Vorerkrankungen sind unauffällig.
Er hat viele verschiedene Medikamente wegen Schmerzen eingenommen.
Er hat keine Linderung.
Die Schmerzmittel haben keine Linderung gebracht.
Voroperationen wurden verneint.
Er hat keine Allergie und Unverträglichkeit.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er ist nicht raucher und trinkt auch nicht.
Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Seine Mutter ist gesund und sein Vater leidet an Depression.
Er hat zwei Brüder und sie sind gesund.
Er studiert Maschinebauingenieur.
Aber er hat keine Arbeit und ist nicht verheiratet und leid.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf Hypochondrische Störungen.
Die Differentialdiagnostik kommt an Depression, Fibromyalgie, Hypothyriose.
Das ist ein Bedrück.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich zuerst Zempatienten körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Ich würde auch Blutbilder, Elektrolyten, Vitamine B12, Vitamin D, Nieren und Leber werden.
Und wenn es ums Wissen geht, würde ich ein Bildgebendeverfahren durchführen.
Und ein psychatrisches Konzil wird auch sinnvoll.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Da hat er keine genaue Diagnose.
Ich würde eine Festdiagnose feststellen.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Ich empfehle dem Patienten zuerst geduld zu sein.
Er hat chronische Symptome seit seiner Kinderheit.
Die Symptome sind für eine psychiatrische Diagnose.
Eine psychiatrische Diagnose festzustellen ist nicht einfach.
Manchmal leiden Patienten unter vielen verschiedenen Beschwerden.
Aber es ist nicht einfach festzustellen.
Vielleicht eine kognitiv verhältnisstherapie ist möglich.
Antidepressive Medikamente werden auch sinnvoll.
Ich empfehle eine Festdiagnose oder eine Therapie.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten Gruppentherapie oder andere Psychotherapie?
Kognitiv verhältnistherapie oder Gruppentherapie ist möglich.
Ich bin kein Psychiater.
Diese Krankheiten sind besonders.
Ich arbeite mit Psychiatern und Psychologen zusammen.
Ich optimiere die Diagnose und die Therapie des Patienten.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine EKG schreiben? Warum?
Ich würde gerne eine EKG schreiben.
Manche Patienten können mit psychischen Symptomen unter Arithmen leiden.
Viele Patienten haben Angststörungen.
Deswegen kann ein Begleitsymptom Arithmen aufstehen.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich das hier machen möchte.
Dann würde ich gerne eine EKG schreiben.
Die Echokardiografie kann auch ein sinnvolles und mögliches Klagenstörungen ausüben.
Manche psychiatrischen Störungen, besonders Panikattacken oder Angststörungen kann mit Klagenstörungen zusammengehen.
Deswegen ist die Echokardiografie auch sinnvoll.
Würdest du in diesem Fall ein EEG durchführen?
EEG? Ich habe keine genaue Erfahrung über EEG, aber um mögliche Geheimpathologien auszuschließen, können wir ein EKG durchführen.
EEG. Elektroencephalographie.
Wie können Sie ein Hypotherose ausüben?
Zuerst würde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Ich taste den Hals ab, ob es Strom gibt oder Schilddrüse, Lampen oder Vergrößerungen gibt.
Beim Schlücken werde ich die Schilddrüse abtasten.
Danach würde ich einen T3, T4 und TSH bestimmen lassen, um eine Hypotherose oder Thyroidunterfunktion auszuschließen.
Wie können Sie Thyroid untersuchen?
Zuerst würde ich die Schilddrüse abtasten.
Ich liege hinter den Patienten und mit Hilfe der Hände abtasten, werde ich die Schilddrüse abtasten.
Beim Schlücken werde ich auch die Schilddrüse abtasten, um die Vergrößerungen oder Lampen zu bestimmen.
Wenn der Patient einen Suizid gedacht hat, was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Wenn der Patient einen Suizid gedacht hat, werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Welche Antidepressiven verschreiben Sie dem Patienten?
Es gibt viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Herr Oberarzt, Sie können mir SSRI oder SNRI schreiben.
Können Sie mir die SSRI vorstellen?
Das ist ein ...
Was würde ich sagen?
Rehaptik-Inhibitör.
Rehaptik-Inhibitör, aber SSRI.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, Herr Oberarzt. Ich werde gerne recherchieren.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einen CT-Destadest durchführen. Warum?
CT-Destadest kann auch durchgeführt werden.
Es ist unmöglich, einen Gehirntumor auszuschließen oder eine degenerative Gehirnpathologie auszuschließen.
Die degenerative Gehirnpathologie führt manchmal mit Depressionen zusammen.
Und wenn es chronisch schmerzt, wird es zusammenführen.
Deswegen werde ich ein CT-Destadest oder MRT-Destadest durchführen.
Können Sie in diesem Fall Lumbar-Funktion durchführen?
Wenn wir einen neurologischen Befund haben,
dann wird eine Lumbar-Funktion auch sinnvoll.
Unmögliche chronische degenerative Erkrankungen auszuschließen.
Wenn wir eine Neuro-Infektion haben,
dann wird eine Neuro-Borealus oder Neuro-Syphilis auszuschließen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich. Sehr schön.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Markus Winkler.
Herr Markus ist 75 Jahre alt.
Er ist 43 Jahre alt, 75 Kilogramm schwer, 1,78 Meter groß.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seiner Kindheit ganzkörperlichen Schmerzen vor.
Der Patient hat seit einem Jahr die Schmerzen.
Der Patient ist deswegen sehr schwer.
Er hat viele andere Arztinnen und Arzt.
Aber es wurde bei ihm nicht genau die Diagnostik festgestellt.
Er hat zwei Monate lang die Diagnostik festgestellt.
Der Patient hat viele Medikamente nicht verbessert.
Der Patient hat Symptome wie Nervosität, Fatigue, Konzentrationsstörungen.
Der Patient hat Gedanken daran, dass er Borreliosis ist.
Aber der Patient wurde nicht von einer Zecke gebissen.
Die Frage nach Hypostese, Paralysie, Suizidgedanken wurde verleint.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Insomnie.
An Vorerkrankungen gibt es keine bestimmten Vorerkrankungen.
Der Patient wurde nie operiert.
Der Patient nimmt nur ein Schmerzmittel ein.
Er ist nicht Raucher.
Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Der Vater ist gesund. Die Mutter hat Depression.
Der Patient hat zwei Brüder. Sie sind gesund.
Der Patient ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unaufällig.
Er arbeitet in seinem Vaterbüro.
Er hat keinen Stress. Er ist ledig und hat keine Kinder.
Sie wohnt alleine.
Ich gehe von einem Verdag auf Hypokondri.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommt auch Depression, Hypothyroise in Betracht.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome.
Der Patient hat seit seiner Kindheit ganzkörper Schmerzen.
Noch einmal bitte.
Deswegen sind die Patienten viele andere Arten gewesen.
Aber es wurde im 5. Diagnose festgestellt.
Der Patient hat auch Müdigkeit, Nervosität, Fatigue, Konzentration, Störungen.
Diese sprechen für Hypokondri.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst den Patienten die Wetterparameter überweisen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperliche Unterzucht durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Unterzucht werde ich spitzieren, auskultieren, palpieren alle Körper.
Und danach werde ich eine neurologische Unterzucht symbolisieren.
Dabei werde ich Störungen motorisch, sensorisch und andere Störungen verlegen.
Neben der körperlichen Unterzucht werden Laborunterzucht sinnvoll.
Um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten, werde ich Blutbild und TSH, BSG, CRP, Elektrolyte, T3, T4 bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten EEG durchführen, um mögliche Geheimpathologien auszuschließen.
Wenn es einen neurologischen Befund gibt, werde ich den Patienten eine MRT des Schadens durchführen, um mögliche Geheimpathologien auszuschließen.
Sollte ich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten eine Stabilisierung ausüben.
Zunächst werde ich den Patienten einen Phenosynchro-Sugang legen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten eine Flüssigkeit zuführen.
Außerdem werde ich den Patienten eine psychologische Konzilierung anbieten, um meine Verkaufszeiten zu verhindern.
Dann werde ich den Patienten eine psychologische Konzilierung anbieten, um meine Therapie zu optimieren, um meine Verkaufszeiten zu verhindern.
Nach der akuten Behandlung werde ich den Patienten eine leere Veränderung anbieten, um meine körperliche Bewegung an der frischen Luft zu verhindern.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich die geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Vielen Dank, meine Kollegen, für diese schöne Vorstellung.
Wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe, ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose Hypokondrie, richtig?
Ja.
Wie können wir eine Hypokondrie feststellen?
Wenn wir eine Hypokondrie feststellen, müssen wir alle anderen Krankheiten, die wir als Differenzialdiagnose denken,
wenn es keine Befunden gibt, können wir diese Diagnostik feststellen, Herr Oberarzt.
Sie haben gut gesagt.
Wie zum Beispiel, welche organischen Pathologien müssen wir ausschließen?
Ja, es könnte sein, dass der Patient eine Gehirntümer hat.
Müssen wir eine CT-Destrade oder MRT-Destrade durchführen und mögliche organische Pathologien ausschließen.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei einer Gehirntümer?
Wenn der Patient eine Gehirntümer hat, dann ist der Patient sehr störig, sehr spraß.
Aber bei Gehirntümern bin ich mir unsicher, warum der Patient diese Symptome nicht hat.
Ja, Herr Oberarzt.
Leidet der Patient unter depressiver Stimmung?
Ja, der Patient hat auch eine depressive Stimmung.
Der Patient hat Konzentrationsstörungen und Müdigkeit und Schlafstörungen.
Der Patient hat mir gesagt, dass er eine Freundin finden möchte, die diese Schiebe für depressive Stimmung hat.
In welcher organischen Pathologie können wir auch eine depressive Stimmung feststellen?
Ja, Hypotheroise zum Beispiel oder Elektrolyseprobleme oder Multiple Sclerosis vielleicht, aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Aber Hypotheroise und metabolische Elektrolyseprobleme wie Sodium oder Kalsium oder andere,
ich denke es ist möglich sein, dass der Patient eine depressive Stimmung hat.
Welche anderen Symptome erwarten Sie bei einer Hypotherose?
Ja, bei der Hypotherose hat der Patient bradycardi, trochaner Haut, kalte Gefühle.
Das ist ein Supris für Hypotherose, Herr Oberarzt.
Könnten Sie bitte mal für uns eine zyroide Untersuchung erklären?
Ja, bei einer körperlichen Untersuchung oder anderen.
Der Patient muss auf einem Platz sitzen und ich stehe den Patienten hinter.
Ich halte den Patienten auf, ob es eine Vergrößerung oder Knoten oder Schwellungen gibt.
Ok, tasten wir genau an?
Wir müssen das hier testen.
Wir achten, ob Knoten oder Schwellungen oder andere Ferranderungen gibt.
Ob die Schütterung fest ist oder nicht.
Also beim Schlucken?
Ja, beim Schlucken. Ich habe vergessen Herr Oberarzt.
Also wir benutzen Ihre Hände und wir partieren.
Wir sagen, dass der Patient schluckt, wenn der Patient schluckt, werden wir die Palpeen schlucken.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Danke schön, Herr Oberarzt.